the documentary that's coming up the
Lost century and how to regain it the
you said there's a plan for there to be
a
push of something open source with
regard to energy how's that coming does
that come along with the website like
how does that work does that come a week
before a week after no let me be clear
we don't have any Tech we don't have an
inventor or a Technology Group that's
willing to do that because they're like
you know the movie uh Lord of the Rings
my precious my precious Golem with his
ring
ironically some of them are toroidal
rings
um those folks do not want to lose
control of it and ownership of it by
open sourcing it but they don't
understand if they would open source it
and connect to a big group uh strategic
group like we've created that could get
the word out to a billion people I mean
you know my first here here's how how I
sort of out of the box I think about
stuff like this everybody wants to go
through a normal Venture Capital rounds
of funding which
is ridiculous because if you had a
company that had a market cap of what
Tesla Motors does of a trillion dollars
it's not enough it's too little and it's
too late the only way we're going to fix
this existential crisis on the planet is
that these Technologies are released
open source and there are a thousand
companies that are developing it now the
person who developed it originally it's
like if you invented the first xerox
machine there's going to be a huge
inflow of support but the other thing
the reason that thinking is so not
correct
is that there's 1.5 billion cars on the
road that have to be retrofitted and
converted they're two and a half billion
homes well what general electorate
General Motors Amazon and apple
altogether could not do that in 20 years
and it has to be done in 20 years so
this is like a I call like a global
Marshall Plan like the plan that we had
to rescue Europe after World War II
where we put together you know the
funding and the strategy to resurrect
From the Ashes Western Europe well this
is a global plan that has to happen it
has to happen within 20 25 years and to
do it you need a huge amount of
involvement it can't be something where
you're sitting on it secretively
ironically the secretiveness about this
is what gets people killed number one
because they're targeting themselves so
like let's say you uh Kurt have one of
these devices and you have a team of 12
investors and physicists and
electromagnetic Engineers it'd be so
easy to rub you out and you'd vanish and
who the hell would ever know about
this is what happened to the team that
got the Stan Meyer archive you know
because he Stan Meyer not only had a car
that was running on water it was
actually running on zero point we can
get to that in a moment if you want to
hear the physics of it
um and the uh that he also had a device
that had a national security order on it
that we knew about had photographs of it
and it was like a torroid and it was
putting out enormous amounts of energy
way more than you had to supply to it
because it was also accessing this um
very high voltage electromagnetic charge
system that Taps into and creates sort
of a space-time cavitation from the zero
point and this is what they're doing
so that ended up being can you talk more
about the physics too
you said you could talk about the
physics
well yeah but I mean it's if you're if
you're talking to a general audience
who's gonna no one's going to care about
pointing vectors and the what Maxwell
equations were altered and all that
stuff
um but what I'm trying to get to is that
they
we were trying to get it but they had a
big funder that outbid us for the Stan
Meyer Warehouse
including this toroid
and that was the real action by the way
not the car
well a couple years later you know I had
huge amount of funding it was up in
Michigan I finally get a call from Lord
somebody I won't say his name uh in the
British Isles who had been the Thunder
and he was in a panic he says look
they're on the run for their lives
they've got all this stuff operational
now remember the day that it slipped
into that world where they were going to
try to monetize it secretively I said
these are all Dead Men Walking I said
that you know the way they're doing this
is guaranteed to fail it is guaranteed
to fail
but now finally this Lord so and so
calls me up I don't he got my number
somehow and he's in a panic and I'm here
in Washington I said let me write a
strategic overview
of what needs to happen within 24 to 48
hours
because they were saying oh we're going
to go to an eco-friendly country I said
you'd have to go to an eco-friendly star
system there's nowhere on this planet
where this these the henchmen who want
to keep this secret won't get you and
find you it's just not going to happen
um they don't rep they don't recognize
any geopolitical country boundaries for
their operations tactically so I said
look you do this so it was exactly what
we're talking about you open source it
immediately you then hand off all that
information to us and I will get
you know 20 of the top celebrities
working on this to announce it to all
their fans and get all the fan girls and
Fanboys of people like from Justin
Bieber to whoever you know Godsmack to
Justice Beaver yeah they're all really
into it so um so what what I tell people
is that why because I said because
you're going to get blocked at the media
level which is controlled by corporate
there are shills for big corporate
interests you're gonna get blocked by uh
the tech companies but what they cannot
block are these big influencers who have
100 200 million followers on Instagram
or wherever and those people have one of
these devices running their house how
are you going to stop if
one of these A-list celebrities or 20 or
30 of them have their cars and their
house running no it you know people say
what's a pierce now I said no it's not
it's a way to get around the Embargo of
this information through the corrupt
media so I said but look this is what
this is what you got to do you got to do
it very quickly now the next thing I
know they they had decided they were
going to still keep it secret they
wanted to be you know like Gollum and
gone with the Lord of the Rings and hold
on to their precious might
they were to my knowledge all but one of
them were killed they all vanished okay
so let's talk about the physics of the
precious man I was involved in that very
very specifically it's very sad
so the physics aspect you mentioned that
people may not people just so you know
come to this podcast in particular for
the technicalities of physics that's
what we're our main right is physics
okay so you're welcome more than welcome
to speak as advanced as you like well
one one thing to look at is the is the
resource that has been done
um by people like Ken shoulders who who
since have passed away who had his
charge cluster arrays and basically what
those were were little tiny ball
lightning
and it's now been discovered that these
little electrostatic ball lightning type
packets when they discharge they're
actually perturbing or stimulating this
this Quantum flux zero point field of
energy and it causes a a cavitation in
space-time that causes an enormous uh
force of forward moving force that can
be put against the pits and or turn a
rotor for a generator or what have you
most scientists over the last hundred
years didn't know how that was happening
it got imaged uh not too long ago very
very well by a scientist a physicist in
Tokyo I believe it's University of Tokyo
Africa is the gentleman's name where
they were able to image that this is
what was going on
now that's true of whether it was Stan
Meyer with his electrostatic system to
create hydrogen and oxygen gas
the hydrogen and oxygen gas from
dissociating you have to you know beat
the Faraday constant you know the amount
of electrical injury it has to go into
from an electrolyzer to separate the
bond of hydrogen and oxygen which is
what H2O water is in this case the even
the amount of hydrogen and oxygen gas
wouldn't explain how far that car would
run because if you calculate the energy
of what's in that hydrogen and oxygen
gas so what it was really doing and this
is because it was doing it on demand it
was actually accessing this excess
energy let's call it from this Baseline
Quantum flux field or Zero Point Energy
field through these high voltage uh
circuits now I don't think Stan Meyer
understood the physics so because that's
just now getting increasingly elaborated
a very good source for this is Maury
King's book that talks about water uh
the the source of new energy and the
zero point
um it's a bit dense because he's an
engineer and it's a but if you're a
physicist I'd recommend you take a look
at that book Maury King we just
interviewed him about this so there are
many ways to do it it's basically people
have done it with different media you
can do it through an electromagnetic
crystalline substance you can do it
through water you can do it this through
the circuitry of
electrically charged steel like the
Holcomb device down in Florida and you
can also do it through solid-state
oscillator resonance where you're having
the same effect
uh in in these and the key thing is here
vhv very high voltage systems at certain
frequencies and the sort of little what
you look at when you look at it
microscopically these tiny ball
lightning type phenomenon that create
this sort of cavitation and space time
how high of a voltage are we talking
about
Millions
I mean it depends on what you're doing I
mean votes yeah but at very low low Uh
current so the power is very low so you
might put 100 watts into a system and
get you know a kilowatt out or five
kilowatts out ultimately you know I just
was at a place out in the desert uh
Arizona where we witnessed this is going
to be we're going to show this on our
our pod not podcast our webinar on
October 25th
this device that had I think it was four
magnesium alloy plates and this
particular device was more like an
original Tesla sort of a miniaturized
version of warden cliff where this guy
for after 40 Years of trying to do this
something that's a little bit bigger
than a shoe box
and at the startup Powers three volt
battery which you could take out and
it's actually pulling the magnetic flux
and the What's called the negative
energy that's around us uh and it's it
was when we were there a few weeks ago
it was had been running for over two
years this negative energy around us
well he calls it negative energy I think
it's what I think a lot of these terms
are fungible because they're still being
defined I think what he calls negative
energy is actually an aspect of the the
zero point the quantum flux field
um so with you know without getting too
much further into those weeds what the
strange thing about his device it has to
be tuned to the magnetic field and of of
the earth exactly where it is because
it's actually feeding off the flow of
energy from the Sun to the Earth and the
magnetosphere it's very interesting very
it's very tesla-like but instead of it
being this gigantic thing it's like this
big I mean you know so we're there and I
we test it there are no wires going into
it it's putting out
um it was putting out we've got it
around five kilowatts
and no energy input now uh interestingly
even when it was started it was a little
three volt battery tiny little battery
so this is quite ingenious you could
certainly uh it's probably not as robust
it can't be like put in a vehicle and
move because it's tuned to this
frequency of on the earth you know
anywhere you go on Earth there's a
magnetic field frequency so his system
is dependent on that being tuned others
are not others are not so there are many
ways to scan this cap but this was a
very fascinating but again he had made
every conceivable strategic mistake to
guarantee it will never benefit Humanity
and so in a way it was a case in uh
looking at of course this guy is you
know quite up there in years now
um he's also you know a scientist but he
he really thinks he's going to somehow
beat the power grid companies by
creating a megawatt plant and selling it
to the
selling it to the utilities I said no
those companies are vertically and
horizontally integrated into people who
do not want this solution and the laws
around and regulations around tapping
into the Grid or so regulated by state
federal and local bureaucracies that
they'll kill this and strangle it in its
great cradle in two seconds so what I
find is that you find these ingenious
devices attached to completely wacky
strategies because they're they're not
figuring in their strategy of how to get
it out what their adversary is capable
of and then here's your big mistake you
cannot underestimate your adversary and
your adversary is you know got more
power and wealth than the entire US
government and very exotic Technologies
to get in your way I mean when I say
exotic the studying of this sort of
Science and Technology what the cie guys
call wsfm this whole area of science is
Weird Science and freaking magic what's
it called again repeated once more
wsfm if you ever hear that term in the
Carters of some contractor it's a weird
science and freaking magic
um
Northrop Grumman they just call it pfm
pure magic excuse my language
but uh but but they call it magic
because you have all this phenomenon
that happens it's not magic it's just
like it's it's new science
um but let me interject if you don't
mind I'd like to get into the weeds I
know that you want to get out of the
ways let's just delve into for a tiny
bit so how does one produce the voltage
that's required the millions or tens of
millions of volts practically well some
of them don't need that but some of them
do like at this gentleman he just had a
startup once he tapped into the
frequency
and the magnetic field right there he
would have this small three volt battery
to start the initial resonance in these
plates there's a group up in Canada that
has a very similar system so not all of
them have to have that but your some of
your classical uh systems for example T
Townsend Brown and his ability to create
this lifter of anti-gravity effect or
gravity control effect
you're talking to a classically trained
person I have issues with the zero point
so for instance you need a difference it
doesn't matter if there's energy around
you and then if there is then why
doesn't it create a black hole because
then you would need Quantum field Theory
and general relativity so there are many
questions that arise if if you don't
mind just like what is it what is meant
by what is what is this frequency and
what's meant by tapping into the
frequency
it's what what I'm trying to say in late
terms so I mean I don't know how far to
if you have let's say you have a two
million volt
uh system but very low current you know
so yeah maybe it's only you know static
electricity by the way is millions of
volts like when it's cold and you you
zap that's millions of volts but
incredibly low power because there's not
much current
if you have a sustained uh voltage like
that at certain frequencies hurt cycles
per second
it will create
basically as some have described it a
vector a perturbation of the Ambient
Energy field and cause
as as Maury King describes it sort of
this cavitating effect uh from the zero
point where it actually pulls out some
little bit of it now remember it's been
estimated that you know at the level of
Zero Point Energy uh the the volume of
of inside a coffee mug that much space
amount of space has enough potential
power to boil off all the Waters of the
planet
minor liquidity here static electricity
is on the order of fifteen thousand
volts and not a million or tens of
millions I believe Dr Greer simply
misspoke as we all do and I'm correcting
here in part so that you don't go trying
to build a device wondering why the heck
is not working or ruining your family
dinners with physics tidbits like I do
so it's it's you know this is why you
test to kind of referred to it although
they didn't understand that's what it
was the sort of infinite energy field
but to actually access it you have to do
these uh various physics and
electromagnetic engineering uh
techniques and it's different for
different substances if it's just
electric steel which is what Dr Holcomb
is doing with his Holcomb Energy System
that's different from what this
gentleman in the desert was doing with
the magnetic field of the earth which
was different from what Stan Meyer was
doing with water but the principles you
know the under this is why you know one
of the things I've been advocating is
some Venture capitalists who actually
you know you know there's billions of
dollars being spent on pseudo solutions
that someone puts together
and this is also going to be one of the
appeals we're going to make an open
source
physics research and development lab
funded to you know 50 to 100 million
dollars to start with so that you can
put the best people in place study these
devices that have come and gone and
optimize it into a solid-state system
that's stable that could begin to be
moved out to the public I think that if
you had such a facility and support and
it was done open source you'd probably
would have uh at least your first system
developed within one to two years uh and
and at that point it would have to be
massively disclosed